[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in today's video we're going to be
discussing severus snape
voldemort nagini and the deathly hallows
more specifically we're going to be
taking a look at the last moments of
severus snape's life
diving in even further we're going to
exploring why
severus snape didn't defend himself
against nagini
and if he could have in fact survived
had he wanted to
snape dying was a pivotal moment in the
series
particularly as just shortly after his
death his true motivations are revealed
to harry
but did he have to die why couldn't he
have defended himself
snape's death came after voldemort who
sought ownership of the elder wand
came to the realization that snape was
likely its true owner
which we of course know not to be the
case from voldemort's perspective
in order to become the one's new owner
snape would need to die
in response to this voldemort ordered
nagini to attack
and kill snape why doesn't it work for
me severus
in the silence harry imagined he could
hear the snake hissing slightly
as it coiled and uncoiled or was it
voldemort's sibilant sigh
lingering on the air my my lord said
snape blankly
i do not understand you you have
performed extraordinary magic with that
wand
no said voldemort i have performed my
usual magic
i am extraordinary but this wand no
the elder wand cannot serve me properly
zephyrus because i
am not its true master the elder wand
belongs to the wizard who killed its
last owner
you killed apples dumbledore while you
live severus
the elder wand cannot truly be mine my
lord
snape protested raising his wand it
cannot be any other way
said voldemort i must master the wand
severus
master the one that i master potter at
last
and voldemort swiped the air with the
elder wand it did nothing to snape
before a split second seemed to think he
had been reprieved but then
voldemort's intention became clear the
snake's cage was rolling through the air
and before snape could do anything more
than yell it had encased him
head and shoulders and voldemort spoke
in parcel tongue
kill there was a terrible scream harry
saw snake's face losing little color
it had left it whitened as his black
eyes widened
as the snake's fangs pierced his neck as
he failed to push the enchanted cage
of himself as his knees give away and he
fell to the floor
in an older video of mine i discussed
the theory
that snape never actually died provided
that snape died from nagini's venom
i deduced that it was likely that snape
a potions expert
took some form of slow acting anti-venom
in order to remain alive
after the anti-venom kicked in snape
simply slipped away
from where he was known starting life
anew having achieved
some degree of vindication for the death
of lily
if you want to know more about that
theory go and check out my video on it
which i'll link in the description
so why did snape powerful wizard master
of deceit
and powerful tactician not fight back
against a giant snake
surely with his level of power he could
have handled nagini
easily right here's the thing about
snape's death
he did try to protect himself he was
just caught off guard
particularly by voldemort's decision to
use nagini
the first thing snape did when voldemort
mentioned that he would need to die
is raise his wand my lord snape
protested
raising his wand at this stage voldemort
swipes the air with the elder wand
but nothing happens prompting snape to
believe that he may have been reprieved
effectively bringing his guard down
snape wasn't sure of the degree to which
his life was in danger
which is why he hesitated and why he
didn't just immediately attack voldemort
the second that he threatened him amidst
the confusion
he saw voldemort cast a spell that did
nothing causing him to
further believe that perhaps he was safe
however
at this moment out of nowhere snape is
suddenly stuck inside of a magical cage
with nagini
screaming for his life what it boils
down to is that snape was just caught
off guard
for years he had successfully acted as a
double agent
he could trick anyone and he was a
master of the mind
for him to be turned on by voldemort was
massively unexpected
and for snape someone who was always so
in control
it wasn't an outcome that he had
considered had snape not been so perhaps
arrogant in his ability to remain in
control of situations
one step ahead of everyone else then i
think that he very well
could have survived did you guys ever
think about this
let me know in the comment section below
until next time
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget
to live
you